eight news now in nevada we certainly
know about
gun violence we had the highest number
of people killed in an
incident in modern history a nevada
democratic congresswoman
working there to pass gun control bills
house democrats say the
two gun control bills they are poised to
pass
would make the country safer our
washington correspondent alexandra limon
has the details of the measures
and also tells us why it's going to be
tough for them to actually become
law democrats are pushing for passage of
two bills to strengthen background
checks for gun sales
if you are a felon if you are a criminal
if you are deranged
well by god you shouldn't have access to
a weapon that's what this bill does
it has the support of about 90 percent
of americans
illinois congresswoman sherry bustos
says one bill would close the so-called
gun show loophole
by making it illegal for unlicensed
persons to transfer firearms to someone
else without a background check listen
i'm a father
of a five-year-old is in school i care
deeply about gun violence
republican congressman richard hudson
says these bills are not the solution
these bills again would have not stopped
a single
mass shooting but democrats say the
second bill which would extend the
background check period from 3 to 10
days
would give authorities more time to flag
people like the charleston church
shooter
nevada congresswoman dina titus says the
bills still respect the gun rights of
americans
but that doesn't mean that people who
shouldn't have guns can go out and use
them in our streets as weapons of war
republican senator marco rubio says he
doubts the bills will improve
gun violence the people aren't going to
follow the law are criminals
the people that are buying guns in the
back alley if they pass in the house the
bills would still need to gain support
from
every democrat and 10 republicans to
pass in the u.s senate
in washington alexandra limon